before I like it when people are with
that adrenaline rush and shout no
when they shout when they boo you when
they applaud you that they transmit a lot of
positive energy is that sometimes one is born for
something and I think I was born for wrestling
my name is meridanos
my  pseudonym of wrestler juanita la
affectionate and I started very young in
wrestling there weren't many opportunities
for women back then but when
this cholita wrestler arrives as
a boom but also as a criticism,
affection for a woman in a skirt, she is very
demure, no  they show their legs
easily, so in this sport
we do somersaults and jumps and the
flights that we do are really that
we show the legs of all the servant
criticism of our society of our
same gender towards us but at the same
time also an admiration
because it is difficult  go up with the shirts
and be a fighter up there
if I like to fight with men
because they are the strongest sex with
more frightening problems  stronger than the woman and
show them that a woman
can also hit them hard we know that he is
stronger but he is not intelligent it is more
each of our colleagues has
families could be a fighter mother of a
housewife it is difficult
I think we are worth a lot as fighters and
women